what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels
as you guys know before i start the
video do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily
videos while you're at it guys cool
thing happened to me over
this weekend was i actually got to meet
the demilio family and i have pictures
on my instagram so if you guys want to
see those
go check out my instagram okay
let's go right
to it
29 you hear
oh every time a girl is over the age of
like 26
27
he's always like what do you got on the
topic
so you were talking about like having a
high value man
and the question i ask is
why should the should the top 10 to 15
of men
care what the bottom 80 to 85 of women
want
or say i think that they should care
because it's like a difference in
mindset
between them and then the top 15 of
women you know
so when you start to notice um what
those type of women want it gives you
more value in the top 15 percent of
women
but they don't want them yeah
i mean but it's like you know no no no
no
no if you were if you were a 10 let me
just do this if you were 10
okay universally attend
would you honestly care about what an
average man thought no
come on honestly it only really matters
what the person you're dating thanks
that's really it
dude i mean it depends on what i do no
no
no no no thank you for relationships
why then why is it why is it different
for you if you were a 10
exactly i mean because it's like it just
depends on what you do
like no it doesn't we're talking about
i'm not talking about some fans i'm not
talking about celebrity guys
okay i'm talking about vp emerges and
acquisition i'm talking about the
business class
but those guys cheat on their wives with
the lower women
but but who's the wife
see let me tell you something the wives
don't care
bill melinda gates didn't care that bill
was cheating because she was the wife
and the girl that was cheating because
it's side chick see what you prove
is that women don't like the double
standard
right you're good with being a 10 and
not caring with an average guy because
you know there's no way in hell
you would marry him screw him or
anything but yet you feel as though that
men should care about what average women
think
just i agree with that like it
it only matters the person that you're
date with the person you're dating
because what because they have sex with
them yeah
no that just means you're an orgasm
oh damn damn
sorry i just think it's hilarious
because there's basically what's this
time what state do you live in
california what city
l.a go out and drive it around l.a and
count the number of adult
the female and the strip clubs that are
for men and let's count the strip clubs
that are for women
there's literally i don't think there
even is a women's strip club anymore
thank you there used to be one why do
you think that it is
because women aren't spending money like
that on men they're looking
for men to spend money on them
men understand first up
you don't like the fact that a man will
have sex
with an average woman but he ain't gonna
marry her
that's what strip clubs and [ __ ] are
for damn
what about the nba players again
okay i need you to understand something
i need you to focus please
please stop asking me about celebrities
entertainers
and athletes can you stick to the people
that we are
yeah but who can i give you an example
of that you wouldn't know
well i don't care about them because
their their world is different
right okay
i don't give a [ __ ] see the problem is
if you have to stick to the conversation
right here you can't win
because that's no different than me
sitting around talking about rihanna and
beyonce and sweetie
do you know them ah no i mean i've been
to their parties
thank you but you you paid them i didn't
pay them
did you get the point somebody paid them
for you
yeah i guess so thank you i'm talking
about the kind of men that you would be
competing with somebody else for
see that's the you ladies don't like to
stay in reality because you just want to
be right
are you married no do you want to be
married
yes you want children yes
do you think your husband will be a
musician
an actor or an athlete probably
wait really i'm serious probably
those are the men that i've dated how
old are you
29 no
i don't know i mean i have a
i have a pretty good uh resume
of dicks yeah yeah my book is nice
yeah your [ __ ] your roster of dead dicks
is nice but you got nobody
i don't know why girls brag about that
stuff so no
that's not because you're a side chick
no
i've actually been proposed to before
and before or after the orgasm oh
i actually damn something is the one guy
who proposed to me i didn't have sex
with him
that was this and all joking aside but
yeah
was this when you were in college or was
this
i was about 27 and i was like
about two years ago and is he did he
play professional sports or like
canadian basketball
no he played in the nba and okay and if
you turned him down
why because he had seven kids
with six different women and i did
you can't make this [ __ ] up you can't
make this [ __ ] i
yeah i didn't want to be so why in the
hell
would you you deserve what you get
and that's why we laugh at women like
you
i ask if you want to be married do you
want to have kids and when i ask you do
you think your husband's going to be in
this group of men
who tend to live this lifestyle you say
yes and that's what you openly pick for
instead of going over and dating men
over on the business side because
here's the problem you can't handle a
man over here because you've got to be
more than just
cute i have more than that to offer
well then why are you why are you
putting yourself in a group of men
who you say do these things
i i don't know in l.a it just seems like
that's
that's just everybody you know excuse me
like we're the dating scene the dating
scene is only nfl
nba how many people live in l.a i'm sure
it's a lot of people like that
like with the amount of music that's the
entire dating scene
there's huge corporations in l.a no i
mean everybody else is like you know
uber drivers or
you know door dash drivers and i make a
decent amount of money myself so it's
just like
guys that's what i got i didn't i didn't
pay her i swear to god i didn't pay her
it's like i i don't want to date
somebody who makes less
or does less than me did you go to
college
yes where where did you graduate from
usc
what do you do for a living um tv film
what is that like i'm i'm doing two
movies at the end of the month
are you an actress or are you in front
of camera behind an actress
okay i make a good amount of money
men don't care about your money men pick
women based upon what
their looks and what they have to offer
no that looks in their body
that's where it starts yeah so
on the scale how tall are you i'm 5 10.
dress size about four how much did you
weigh the last time you weighed yourself
160
uh he's like
i'm trying to fix i'm 5 11 and a half
160 would that be a size 4.
um i'm not about to have you guys roast
me for my dress size so i'm not gonna do
that but i'm trying to think
what do they say like ten pounds is a
dress size so if i lost
i don't think that would be a size four
but that's just my
two cents if you had to rank yourself on
the scale from zero to ten you can't use
seven
fresh face out of the shower your hair
what would you give yourself
okay and i consider it tend to be
i know you don't consider beyonce to be
a 10. okay
but i consider beyonce to be a 10.
i don't care
you're six you're cute you're cute but
in nobody's life are you a nine or even
close to jessica alba beyonce
i would say i'm a knight right of course
you should get paid for what i look like
so the episode uh i've made a lot of
money based upon what i'm looking
wheezy got paid for what she looked like
uh uh esther got paid for what she
looked like
that's not that's fair
where are your modeling contracts and if
you're an la9 you should be on the cover
of cosmo
you should be in you should be on the
cover of people she's definitely not
bad looking but i wouldn't give her la-9
no i mean i okay
that's fine how long you may have a nice
body
but i'm saying that in a a six is cute
okay even an adjustable six but i'm not
gonna put you up there with a bi
i wouldn't give you better than beyonce
or jessica so you're saying
this okay i've been i've been all over
the place with saying sweetie
is an adjustable six but you
yeah and you're saying that you look
better than we i i
i would ring wheatie at about a 9.
so you and her so you so you were
sweetie
don't do that to yourself yes i just
have a natural body
okay all right let's keep on
i'm trying to keep you out of this
quicksand because if you
then where's the husband you said you
turned down one
you said you turned down one dude
because he had six kids seven kids but
six women
yeah all right well
you don't get approached do you date
guys who are businessmen
yeah i mean it's just um let's see the
last guy that i dated was a
rapper the guy you see your eyes she's
like
that did not end well he actually runs
um a retail company
um who was before that
i don't remember like i'm with guys like
for a long time
like i have my relationships are lasting
like two
years at the minimum
i know i have no ring
i have no ring and that should tell you
something because you're about to run
smack dab into the wall at 30.
it's a glorious wall and the point is
man
i think you're over valuing yourself but
that's fine it doesn't matter
the point is you're still talking about
men in a very small select group who
have not chosen you
and asking you about dating men who in
the business sector and honestly the
vibe you're giving is
they're not on your level no
it's not that they're not on my level
it's just i go to different things like
i think she's just saying
that like based on the places she goes
that's who she meets from my work and
what i do
and the events i go it's like where am i
supposed to meet them
i don't know all right okay bumble
tender hit like
so um do you want are you a dog you're
going to eat harmony
are you a dog person harmony are you a
dog person or a cat person a dog person
i'm a dog
i bet you dude why did you say that
there's nothing i have a whole saying
buy a dog and die alone
you're the same you're talking about i
go to these places in that place
due respect man vegan tv film
cool you make money cool but oftentimes
you ladies get it confused you confuse
your socioeconomic status
right as to your sexual marketplace
value those aren't the same
there are women who make more than you
who look better than you who go to these
same places
yeah and they're still not married to
these guys because these guys aren't
picking you
well i think a lot of times girls will
get like
attention from a certain level again and
think that's like their level
because they'll see the other girls he
like associates himself with when they
who do these guys marry
they tend to marry average looking women
i'm telling you when i see the guys with
their wives their wives
and when did they marry these women when
i don't know i have no idea i've never
really asked oh they marry him after the
millions so they marry him before
oh usually it's before the mill thank
you
thank you thank you thank you
thank you before you're saying that they
married them in and build them up no
who's excuse you well
you think those chicks you think those
chicks built those men
they had to have had some some hand in
it right
like why would you just well you don't
think that this is where i
probably disagree with kevin you don't
think that the people you associate
yourself with have any effect on like
how you do
you don't think it's helpful to a guy to
have a good woman by his side
i'm not saying like she did all the work
like it was definitely him like
obviously if she's talking about actors
and entertain like
basketball like
very clearly she they did not help their
husbands with their handles
but what what she's trying to say is
she's trying to say
that they like helped him come up so
they made it easier for him to come up
you think that the men just built
themselves i think behind every
successful man is a strong woman
guess what that is why you i'm just
letting it go man this is gold
this is what this she is a prototypical
modern foolish woman
well of course he's not gonna think that
though he's been divorced three times
and he still was able to become
successful
and i mean obviously that's not a
hundred percent
true because how many billionaires do
you know that have had one two or three
wives
who built the apartment you're standing
in was a crew of women or crew of man
well this is a house and the house man
who built the car you drive in the crew
of women and crew of men the plumbing
the heating
who built the world you live in
oh boy this is a fool is anything
no i'm being dead serious am i trying to
i tried it back
i tried to back it out but now we're
there you're a fool you're a foolish
woman
yes you are because do you think the god
is a woman dude why are you
woman then why are you in such a [ __ ]
up position
what position single that's not a bad
position
really and who says i'm single unmarried
okay dating men who have six kids myself
seven kids by six women
i don't care being with somebody for two
plus years
if god is a woman you got a problem with
god
no i think that that's a good thing okay
i swear to god i didn't pay her people i
did not pay her
i did not pay her why you got your
comments off
uh look lady i'm trying to be nice to
you
but don't make me go there okay oh no oh
boy is that your child no it's my sister
i'm really trying to be nice to you i
really try to be nice but
what you're showing is the mo the
entitlement of modern women
and then when you guys start losing a
conversation you start becoming little
catty girls
bottom line is man because right there
it's almost 30 years old even if you
have a career
okay you cannot
get what it is you say you want
maybe the kind of men you're going after
don't want
who the kind of woman you are yeah
i can i mean i can see that but it's
just i don't go after men like i don't
live my life to date or to find a man
that's not what i i don't live for that
right and that's
probably why she is where she is so
the people that i've dated are just
people that i just mingled with or met
multiple times you know hung out with
they asked me out
they pursued me what not but i just
don't go after
cool and that's fine and that ends in
casual dating having fun
sex but then you'll almost be 30 in a
few minutes you'll be 35 next thing you
know
if you want to have children where those
kids going to come from you want to have
children do you think that women no no
no no no no no no
find a man your only purpose on the
planet is us
without us you have no problems that's
not true
really show me the place where women
where a single solitary woman can
survive
without the group where can men survive
without the
let's see see i don't know if i agree
with him there
because like okay i know you guys i'm
sure the manosphere are not big
like fans of lizzo but she's not married
and you can tell that she's like
extremely happy like doing what she
loves to do and like her purpose is like
her music her art her everything
i think like she definitely would be
happier with like a boyfriend or
whatever but
like to act like if a girl doesn't get
married she has no purpose on this
planet
uh it's a stretch for me i do agree with
him that women
can't like actually survive without men
though see see what happened folks
when i asked a question she couldn't
handle men and women need no no
no no we don't no no no no no no no see
what happened folks when i asked her a
question she could not handle
instead of being an adult and answering
the question she played the little girl
game i'm going to deflect and redirect
answer the question answer the question
before you ask me a question
women dominate and allow where where can
a woman survive
by herself in my industry and tv no
no no no on the planet i'm not talking
about in the company i'm talking about
on the planet in the environment
okay but i understand what she's saying
all she's saying is that i can get a job
make my money
and do that forever and i'll be fine
obviously she's supposed to be employed
by men employed like
all this stuff is like run by men
clearly but that's what she's trying to
say and that's what people mean when
they say that like
even if i don't get married or i don't
end up like in a relationship
i'll be okay like i have my friends i
have my family i have my job whatever
um i don't think she's discounting that
she wants to be married and like
have really like have kids and all of
that
oh anywhere have you not been naked and
afraid
are you out of your [ __ ] mind women
can't even manipulate them
i'm gonna have so this is going to go
everywhere you don't even have the
hamstring to manipulate the environment
and this is the problem
modern women are so women are so
detached drop me and you
both in a jungle and i beg you that i
would survive you'd be looking at me
like oh how do i build this shack how do
i
how do i start a fire i'm not even no no
sis i was trying to help you
i was trying to help you survival
instincts that have that
just in this in this thing she said
something you have no idea who you're
talking to
no i'm just saying you have no idea who
you're talking to i think you're
underestimating no i
don't uh-huh well then see here's the
funny thing is the difference between me
you have a bunch of opinions backed up
and nothing but except anadolu
experience
this has already been proven out and
demonstrated go to watch bear grylls
island number two
go watch bear grylls island number two
season two where they dropped a bunch of
women and a bunch of men on remote
islands
by the end of six weeks women had almost
died four times and me and it
almost almost built a home you ladies
cannot survive
man be quiet be quiet
no better women you are not strong
enough
no i definitely okay i understand where
he's going with that this is a lot like
closer to my face
than before um no i definitely agree
with kevin there where he's talking
about like
men or women cannot survive like without
men that totally makes sense
um i think sometimes he like purposely
misconstrues like what the girls are
trying to say
like when they're clearly talking about
um
like like having a job and i'm like i'm
not just gonna live my life like to get
married if that doesn't happen that's
what happens um like that's what they're
trying to say but
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree with me do not
forget
to subscribe to the channel and turn
that notification bell on i'll talk to
you guys
next time